the following trailer is rated s for
spoilers today's episode is brought to
you by the u.s. army from the Thanos of
Hollywood comes what could be the best
movie Marvel's ever made but without a
doubt is the most movie Marvel's ever
made
man there is just so much movie in this
movie look at all that movie Avengers
infinity war journey into a new era the
MCU where after ten years of having a
streamline their plots so normies would
know what's happening
Marvel's gotten so big they'll drop you
right into episode 19 part 1 of 2
without wasting a second on who anyone
is or why you should care because let's
face it you're either on this hype train
by now or the Winter Soldier using
Rocket Raccoon as a sidearm one means do
you don't you see they're both cyborgs
rebellion against their destructive
program dead weren't you listening to me
are you yawning all your favorite heroes
are here like Tony Stark
the scientist who finds that magic
exists and takes it in stride he came
here to steal a necklace from a wizard
but literally can't even when another
quippy guy with a goatee shows up what
is your job exactly besides making
balloon animals star-lord whose entire
first movie was completely undone we'd
like to express our profound gratitude
for your help in saving Xander he
decimated zonda and takes it in stride
but literally can't even when another
buff guy with blond hair shows up you
monkey he's trying to copy Captain
America who heroically accepts his
reduced role as guy who knows a guy can
we do that not me not here I know
someone who could find vision crumply
Steve Rogers black panther whose lack of
screen time proves no one knew how big
of a deal he be and spider-man the boy
who'd rather hitch a ride into space and
die than stay home and be in venom you
me both kid but they're not alone
because all these other characters are
also back like Bruce Banner a man in
desperate need of a phase-three recap
video Tony you've lost another super
Bach with Scott and then there's an
ant-man and a spider-man the Avengers
broke up we're toast like a band like
like the Beatles Scarlet Witch the x-man
who's completed her Halle Berry arc of
losing her weird accent as the movies go
on everybody's
of something one of their people who are
expecting me to you know he's both made
promises Gamora the emotional center of
the whole story and the best actor huh
didn't see that one coming Loki slightly
more dead than the last two times the
rest of the Guardians pre James Gunn
petition those were simpler times
a few weeks ago and Bucky the one-armed
artisanal goat cheese farmer but they're
not alone either because holy crap there
are so so many people in this movie like
Rhodey
Ocoee a mantis vision Falcon Wang Shuri
Baku Red Skull Nick Fury
oh hey where you been Thunderbolt Ross
again okay Marisa Hall right this is
their name pepper hey last face one
girlfriend standing good for you
knit Nedry and Hawkeye name where's
Clint Wow the only heroes missing are
the ones on all those Netflix shows
Kevin Feige hates next time iron fist
next time or not for all the characters
crammed into this thing thrill as it
centers around above bald guy trying to
grow his rock collection
no Thanos he's been looking for the
Infinity stone so long he's changed
color twice and after he vowed in age of
Ultron to do it himself
he waited like seven whole movies
including two that took place in space
and then boldly sent more of his kids to
do it for him you sir are a really bad
stepfather but dang what a great dad
oh yeah watch these movies catch up to
one of comics longest-running traditions
briefly killing people off to goose
sales where with a single snap of the
fingers Disney erase the box-office
potential of Black Panther spider-man
5/7 of the Guardians Doctor Strange the
Winter Soldier and one-third of the
Avengers and if you think these deaths
are gonna stick for longer than a movie
I've got a copy of The Death of Superman
to sell you I mean it's still in the
original bag mint condition with the
armband - come on no one how about the
death of Tony Stark
did the Captain America how about Thor
Nick Fury okay okay how about a copy of
infinity gone where the same thing
happens and they'll come back just fine
cool cool so cool story who throws a
moon honestly for Stooges beards of no
nation he was a one-eyed lawn for flying
purple people beater Under Armour Dumbo
to Wong thanks for nothing
signed The Avengers shorty LaForge
a hologram for the King Teen Titan blow
it wasn't me it was the one on Stan do
dodo dodo dodo dodo dodo don't tomorrow
Red Dead Redemption and the dust dust
league
game of stones so we're just gonna give
him a pass for pretending this was a
standalone movie yeah yeah we are
today's episode was brought to you by
the US Army find out more by clicking
the link below
bring me the nose on your next Avengers
infinity war on his trailer we're tiny
we're tunis we're all a little loony we
are venom i should have taken the aiming
to the head elective class back on
Asghar heckling a heckler is not worth a
claim